this is uh nancy mace she's a republican
congresswoman in south carolina she says
that her house was vandalized overnight
this was a couple of nights ago
by antifa and uh she she uploaded a
video
this is kind of interesting because we
hear about these cases all the time
someone on social media saying oh look
at this
hateful graffiti someone has left on my
property and most of the time it's
someone on the left making this claim
and what happens lebron james being one
of them although although the
interesting thing there is he never did
a video
he never actually showed us we never
even saw the graffiti
and then he called he he he called or
someone at his property called the cops
and by the time by the time the cops had
showed up he had already someone had
already painted over the graffiti oh
okay
because that's what you would do but
whether there's video or not whenever
someone on the left
claims that there was their victim of
some kind of hate crime there was
graffiti or there was a racist
note or a hateful note left for them at
their front door or
uh or on their car windshield or
whatever
everyone on the left immediately
believes it unquestioning
yet for some reason people on the left
were a little bit skeptical
of this let's first of all let's watch
let's watch the video here it is
woke up this morning uh to my house
being vandalized
last night um you can see they spray
painted
in black past the pro act on the front
of my house that's
my bike that one of the kids was using
last night
shortly before the house got vandalized
it's very scary they also
spray painted no gods no masters
all politicians are bastards with antifa
markings on it and you can see right in
front of me i'll see on the sidewalks
in the street um out here you can see
where they spray painted cute nancy
um and then they've got antifa symbols
down
with uh some of the other you know
what's what pisses me off is uh makes me
so angry
is that this is a house that i live in
with my kids
my two kids and uh one of them was on
the bike last night
coming in from the movies and they're
not even
my kids aren't even safe on the front
porch of their own home
and it's wrong we can disagree
politically but vandalizing somebody
else's property
is wrong and is illegal so we are doing
everything we can and i
thank our police local police who were
here this morning
um alerting me to what was going on
and want to thank them for their
diligence and figuring out
who did this okay so there it is
now as i said you could go on twitter
and go to
uh go to her twitter account nancy
mace's
twitter account you can see where she
originally posted these videos and then
you can look at the uh the comments
underneath
and it's like 90 from people on the left
including verified account
more accounts more prominent people
outright accusing her
of doing this herself and saying this is
a hoax
and we know of course that if she was on
the left
they would immediately accept it right
away
because they always do they
from from uh from bubba wallace to
justice millet to lebron james and all
of the the less
the lesser-known people who've done
their own hoaxes
on the left they accept all of that
right away so all you have to do is give
her
um different politics and also
preferably a different different
skin color and they would accept that
right away no question
no skepticism and in fact they would say
if you are skeptical of it then you're
racist or you're sexist and you should
believe women and
this is what happens anytime a woman is
victimized she
she tries to talk about it she's always
doubted by by
privileged men and so that that would be
the line right but here
in this one case all of a sudden they've
discovered
skepticism so we knew that was going to
happen
now looking at the case though
objectively
i will say now i have no idea whether
this is legitimate or not i don't know
anything about
nancy mace i'm not making any
accusations i don't know
i i will say first of all that in
in all cases like this where someone is
reporting that there's been graffiti or
a note left or something like that
there should always be skepticism until
proof is offered
and that's that's a good general policy
with all things to have skepticism until
some sort of evidence or
until you're given a real reason to
believe it's
well there's no reason to believe it by
definition
um also it is i will say and i did
notice when i was watching the video
it it it's a it's a it's a curious
that all of the graffiti is on concrete
surfaces
she has she has painted white surfaces
right there
and the the vandals apparently decided
only to to
uh to vandalize the concrete surfaces
where the stuff can be more easily
washed off and it's not a big deal
right in terms of damages
and you would just think if you're a
vandal and you're doing this
and there's a there's nice painted white
surfaces
and you hate this person you're trying
to vandalize their home
you'd think you'd probably spray paint
on those surfaces
i don't know so the fact that they only
chose the concrete services is a little
strange but on the other hand
what what gives it credibility is that
number one she called the police right
away
and many times you find in these hoaxes
the the people who are supposedly
victims are
strangely strangely reluctant to get the
police involved
so she called the police right away also
there have to be security cameras
all over that neighborhood you know this
is a wealthy neighborhood there has to
be
security cameras presumably on her house
and if not on her house then all over
the neighborhood
be very easy to check you would assume
she knows that
and also she's a politician it's kind of
hard to imagine
a politician doing this as a hoax
quite a political risk it's also
dishonest and we know that's not going
to stop any from politicians from doing
it but
and then i'll say this too
this hoaxes of this kind
it's almost always people on the left
doing it
so yes the fact that she's on the right
does grant her a little bit more of the
benefit of the doubt
because this is not this is not common
behavior on the right
on the left this is just what they do
it's it's a common tactic
so we'll see police are involved they'll
look at the
security camera footage and uh i think
we'll know we'll know the truth
pretty quickly the other thing is you
know when it's someone on the left and
they perpetrate a hoax
and the cops discover that it's a hoax a
lot of times they don't really tell us
that
there was a case of althea bernstein and
i think that was in milwaukee i believe
and she remember she was the one who was
at a said she was a stoplight and some
racist white guys came up and set her on
fire
and there of course there are security
cameras all over the place red light
cameras everything she said it happened
in the middle of a city
and um the cops would have figured out
almost right away that it was a hoax but
they didn't really
tell us that or it took them a while to
and even then they didn't say it was a
hoax they just said oh we never found
any evidence of this
in this case if it's a hoax i think that
um there will be no hesitation to let us
know
so we will see well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content